we need one person more staff at this
toronto hospital are performing a
delicate dance
the procedure called proning involves
flipping the unconscious patient onto
their stomach to increase their oxygen
like most in this intensive care unit
the elderly woman has covid19 and she's
unvaccinated now we're really only
seeing critical illness in two types of
patients
them being the unvaccinated patients
and the
patients most in the icu are
unvaccinated patients like dawn who
asked us not to show her face i just
feel that there wasn't enough known
and i wanted to know a little bit more
but in the meantime while the moor is
coming you could be dying she caught the
virus last weekend now she's struggling
to catch her breath i'm going through it
and i'm telling it's not something you
want to play with be careful
do what we're supposed to do and be
vaccinated no i'm terribly sleepy tired
eh
really
i just fall asleep standing up
others like fred lying in a hospital bed
but still standing by his decision not
to get vaccinated i'm still
not sure
oh yeah why do you say that
i don't know it's just a conviction so i
get frustrated when i see an otherwise
healthy person it's a preventable
disease
like if these people got vaccinated
i wouldn't be their doctor i wouldn't be
treating them in the icu over the course
of this pandemic these staff at this
hospital have been performing this
procedure on an almost daily basis but
these days they are doing it with far
fewer hands and that is because this
hospital like so many others is dealing
with an unprecedented staffing shortage
during the first two years of the
pandemic around 500 hospital staff
caught covid19 with omicron they've seen
700 infections just this month the great
majority of our infections come from the
community
at the same time they're also fighting
the fallout from another lockdown a
spike in patients with substance abuse
suicide attempts
and those with other illnesses whose
treatment was delayed by the time this
patient with diabetes saw a doctor her
infection had spread from her toe to her
kidneys the infection has spread
and shut down my kidneys so dialysis is
now
possibly
a life-changing
thing
after nearly two years and five waves
some of those doing the heavy lifting
have had enough i decided to be honest
with you reflecting it
i can't continue like this
fatima mohammed has been an icu nurse
for 15 years i'm tired
and overworked
and underpaid
she says many of her colleagues have
quit or taken early retirement she plans
to do the same after the pandemic is
finally over
jeff semple global news toronto